hello everybody my name is Maxim Daniel
and today I want to speak about
generators python generators in our
ordinary life I don't want to speak
about data oops I already tell about it
and only generator and our ordinary
python code in our life
uh who I am I have around 24 years
experience in software development I
worked 10 years with assembly and last
nine years I work with python
and in between I have learned many other
languages like PHP ISP net and others
all examples from my talk you can found
in repository and or in this repository
you can found also examples from my
other talks
at first I wanted to say thank you for
my team who support me uh Anastasia then
create a design form of whole or my
presentation uh I will be linking
check all my crazy idea and it's my
important critic and Martin I can Reina
is in turn in our company he tested all
my ideas with python and also a shoot to
say thank you for two films who support
me on conferences uh agile group as
a game changer on the uh uh Europe
Union in
a camping industry and websoft this film
and created eCommerce solution for
restricted products this is not too easy
to work with that and we have in our
stack Delphi python react view these
Technologies we use it and right now the
problem which I want to solve with this
talk problem is list and doubles
this is most useless and overrated data
collection in Python why I think so they
require time and memory to create Data
before to use it they require time to
iterate to achieve data and they help to
developers to be lazy and not care about
their own code and we can solve it with
python generators
uh
using generator in our regular life
generator is premised iterations in
future not more of course we have
context switching we have uh stop we can
stop and wait on yield uh we have own
locals Etc but in regular life without I
think a weight syntaxes important is
generator uh premised iteration for you
in future and don't did it in the uh
declaration time of course must read
information from Dave Beasley from 2009
curious course of keratins and
concurrency you can find it you should
check it if you write a python code it's
important
and each generator based on iteration
the introduction of this concept in
Python was on pep 234
and there was introducted also either
function
this is really interesting uh before was
already an introduction about iterations
in pep
2012 but it was too ready for python
community on this idea where it was
rejected
uh okay right now we have either
function we have
um iterable interface what means either
function we can call this function with
two attributes first attributes is
callable second attribute is Sentinel if
result of callable equal to Sentinel uh
either uh throws uh stop iteration
otherwise either returns as a result of
for Call of callable
and if I know this I can create infinity
iterator infinity iterator
calls in integrated as always zero and
the zero is not equal one we can
iterate it
infinity times after that we can create
Infinity generator Infinity generator
for moment in Infinity
carbidem catch the moment and do
something uh
this construction is better than
infinity generators from either tools
and this construction help you stay in
the moment
and
I like it and here I see the biggest
important difference in Loops what I
mean for example I take standard
construction from uh or a leap
connection pool Pi we
have here infinity loop with a while
statement while statement check one
closer
which always true
and after that while loop made one step
and what happens in for Loop in this
time we can use Infinity for Loop but
there we don't have any cloud
on the background python calls next
always and this is too big difference in
for Loop we don't have any closer for uh
next step in while loop we always check
this closet and after that I go away
from while loop I go EO I use always for
Loop also infinity loop
and we can also create stoppable
Infinity uh if Infinity iterator can
call one function I can make something
which may result from this function like
Sentinel and I can throw I can throw a
stop iteration
and I can throw stop iteration outside
from Loop and I can throw stop iteration
inside of my Loop it is important for
our regular life I show it later and
it's also important to know stop it Loop
can reach else block
of course regular generator have already
closed function but right now this
example with
either function and
also somebody can tell me Max is
stupidsu forgot about break statement I
don't forgot about break statement but
break statement break my loop I can go
till end of last of break Loop I go away
from this uh this uh iterate from this
loop it's important breaked iteration
and stopped iteration as two different
things and somebody always forget about
it
example this example from Jungle code I
have many talks about janga on different
conferences and this function created
worked with many objects from database
in this function we have parent Loop and
we have child Loop what we want to do
here we want goes through child Loop and
if something happens we want to break a
parent Loop
how many developer from this code they
created a statement flag if some
happens they change the value from this
flag and it's work it's really something
happens at the end of the loop we
we can throw break we can break our
parent Loop iteration in reality it all
can be simply I show it on the next
slide
but for our regular life at first we
should know a little bit more about
generators and yield statement was
presented in pep 255 uh it's really
interesting to read all this declaration
but sometimes you can found really
strange things there
uh okay yield why we need yield in this
case for example request Library cookies
Pi this function we can call on every
request what we do in this function in
this function we create
in this function we create one list
after that we add
some
elements in list and after that we go
through the new created list of course
we can use create simply generator
which don't create a list which
generated for us some values and after
that result of this generator we can use
in next iteration and this is really
important generator we can use only in
iteration if I use it somewhere else it
not works simply not works and what I
want to
make better in this request cook SPI at
first I can avoid list declaration at
second I can avoid append some value in
this this list and at least I want to
avoid second pass through this list
uh and it seems a little bit shorter on
the right side but it's really
subjective
if you use black for example you don't
care about a short code and okay
what I want to achieve I want to achieve
improvements of memory uses usage and I
won't think this works faster and right
now is important question for you
faster
same it's a really faster or not if I
use generator in my life
who think that generator is faster than
Loop roof list
okay uh who knows what the loop truth
list is faster than generators
yeah
uh especially for you and thorvy stalker
made
um I calculate the speed from this
example
from this example and
answer is
it can be faster but not always fast
sometimes it's faster my experience if
we have at least more than four elements
and not more than 10 000 elements
generator is faster if we iterate this
list
more than one time
I don't know why we have a Peak
Performance if we have around 100
elements in list
a really generate a faster around two
times faster than uh list but after
some some value generator is not too
fast if somebody knows answer why it's
so or probably it depends on my computer
I don't know but please uh you can help
me to to decide why it's
okay right now we know probably kinirata
can be faster but not always
and if you have at least only one
element forget about key narrator you
don't need it
but if you have only one element in list
you don't need a list
okay the next important part of our
python is Pep
289 is generator expressions
like the list comprehensions or
dictionary comprehensions generator
expression can help us to write short
code which we which can work faster for
example a quota from PI Dynamic library
and here you can see on the blog on this
block
generator Expressions do exactly the
same what was in
um
writing pied antique I don't know why a
developer from pediatic wants to write
more code than enough
but generate expression do exactly the
same quote is shorter generate
expression helper to avoid us variable
redefinition on the line five and nine
nine and uh generator expression can
help us to decrease complexity
complexity the this part of code
and I have already talked on the last
python about python code complexity
I know this is really subjective
for somebody work with generator
Expressions it's easy and for somebody
example on the left side is really more
readable funny and easy to work with it
I know what I know I don't know what I
know it's easy and faster to develop
okay we know about engineering about
generate expressions and right now we go
to guinea rather close
I take the example from uh above from
start and here you can see I throw away
the flag declaration and I simply
call the stop iterations from parent
Loop of course I should add the line I
should declare generator for parent Loop
it's easy it's simple you can find many
libraries there you can use this
technique to create a readable and
shorter code for your library
okay
the last element which we should to know
is yield from yield from is easy it help
us
it help us to work with iterables
objects and this is example from Jungle
country padmin I have serious talks
about junk and tripadmin on many genre
cons this is example we create a
read-only fields in form and if user is
not super user one field we want to
add as a read-only field and how it
works on the
line free
we create some list on the line five we
add to this list some value and we
return it
we feel from
the field from I can simply yield from
Super call and after that I can
additional an additional yield the next
value code is shorter and it works but
problem is
if this result result from this function
we use more time it not works we should
check other libraries in our code
uh profit is short clear fast I don't
know probably it's faster
okay by the way uh uh yield from uh uh
in pep
392 was presented a weight which we can
instead use instead yield from but
probably it
this topic for my next talk
and
right now example from my life let's see
on zip implementation python this
implementation can help us transform
Matrix transform matics this
implementation with new pep uh works
better and from python
and what is problem there of course I I
don't like the Tuple conversion on the
end at second I don't like a sentinel
declaration in this code and I simply
don't like built-in zip in Python my
colleagues asks what
and I can answer
I can answer
try to see for this code I can create
only with one liner generator
and I can avoid double this is a big
problem in our real code
and
it was my better zip
uh I uh go through the iterators and I
made
uh yield for it's it's works it
perfectly works
but it's still not enough I want my own
zipv blade check and generators my
colleague
uh my colleague thinks I'm not right and
finally I created this line this is only
one line works like Zip in Python but
without double and all peps which I
already uh says open perhaps you can
found there and important it there you
can before here you can found also close
uh not close again you rather stop
iteration but right now it
the last finally version don't contain
it but it works really it works in our
project I I'm happy but
pep 479
change stop iteration handling inside
generator and it was implemented in
Python try 0.5
and it not works right now
the outer from this pep was Chris and
Guida I have some discussion with Chris
and Chris offer me a to use this
ugly and disgusting Construction in my
yield
I still don't agree and Chris offered me
to open discussion on python forum and
yeah of course I want to do it I'm not
agree with this pip okay pep 479 break
our rules how we work this generator and
I think this pep is wrong
uh
finally yeah
okay don't forget for our regular live
you know we can use Dave Beasley idea
piplines for example
uh this example from Starlet
in config Pi we read file and if I meet
every time a declaration of
Declaration of a dictionary I understand
some there I can use a generator
pipeline
what I mean all what happens in the
parent loop I can use like a generator
at first I should declare a generator
this generator read every line in our
config at second I
transform a readable string at the end
at the end I return dictionary
it works uh I don't know faster or not
but for me and for my team this horror
is is rule we should use a generator in
our work
okay
you can ask me why should we use this
all in our regular life
my answer is because generator leave
only once
and the leaves is short
and it helped us to avoid repetitive
loops it helps to rethink architecture
and it helps avoid data creating if we
don't need this data
for example it can be early stopping in
it can be exception and we really don't
need this data but if list it's already
created why
I don't know
some words about debugging generators
and
we can wrap our generator output data
from our generator in other generator
and we can print every item from
generator or we can lock every item in
generator at second we can use either to
either tools T this created for us
the brother from our generator many
generator and we can use more either
tool spy this help us to check some
elements in our generator
and
some for Loop statistic from ordinary
life
fast typing my life really
fast happy contains only
70 loops and uh around 40 youths it
means
more than 50 percent Loops use generator
iteration
is not well written Library uh
and they contains around 500 loops and
only 100 youth it means uh around 25
percent Loops use generator
this is Library which I like use only
only elf percent of generators but what
is respondents or jungle rest framework
oh
one person and two percent for me it's
only characteristic how unquality code
lays in these libraries
okay
strange many people many people speak
about black clean code hexagonal
architecture tour but they don't care
about data processing in code
uh it's strange for me I don't want to
criticize but I I
sometimes I offer sometimes check your
uh project on for Loop statistic and
think about it
thank you for your attention
you can see example uh in my repository
and my next talk about generator you can
found in Italy in next month thank you
[Applause]
thanks to all of you for listening this
great lecture we spoke earlier you said
you have to have to speak for 30 minutes
he broke it down to just answer your
questions you are typing in on slido I
have just two at the moment so please
read them write them write them please
down at slido so I can read them out
yeah yeah
okay I will come fast but please
try to type them down at slider
so well done on the presentation but I
wanted to say I think you missed one of
the biggest advantages of generators in
your presentation and that we use a
pipeline you can execute them
concurrently
and that even at Short
uh even if it if the iterator is short
it's still fast there then Loops do you
have any experience or suggestions on
pipelining libraries that you can use
Maybe
uh of course this part of generators
should be came in the next talk uh at
first first important thing if you write
our code with generators we can
transform with code in async how its
syntaxes in only in five minutes or okay
in one day full code can work uh uh
asynchronously this is important
important thing why we write synchronous
code with generators we can transform
with this code in asynchronous in
in one click
that's why I like generators I can
transform it but of course in this song
I don't say about it
sorry
next question is is less lines of code
really better code
nine
nine less lines it's not a really better
quote
for me if I can write low lines I
understand how Works my uh my code for
example yeah probably I can be effective
of course if I add commenter if I add
gaps between lines I have many lines of
course
do you think you lose in readability
what you gain in performance or
conciseness by using generators uh
problem is I don't lose readability I
can write my one liner or
generator the normal code
I try to compress a code for
presentation but of course I've write my
code
so if somebody read it he can read it
and yeah we can after see example how I
write
Kenyatta
one liner these many lines it
Finance really readable what I lose I
and their complexity from Full Court
growth I know about it
okay that was the last question because
the time is up but please if you have
any more questions write them down at
slido I talked with Maxim he will answer
them in the Discord channel for the room
b09 thank you
[Applause]